So let us return to our overall
process for case based reasoning.
We have looked at
adaptation a little bit.
Let's not look at evaluation.
The adaptation step has not
given us a candidate solution.
The evaluation step is
concerned with how to
assess the suitability of the candidate
solution to the problem at hand.
So one method of doing evaluation
of a case based solution is
through simulation.
Consider the problem going from
the home to the restaurant.
Case based reasoning proposed
a candidate solution.
In order to find out whether
this solution actually works,
I can do a simulation.
I can even do an execution
in the [INAUDIBLE].
In this case, we might find out
if solution actually works.
And we might accept the solution.
Now, consider an alternative problem.
This time, we have to go from
the restaurant to the home, and
we decided we would simply
flip all the turns.
But as we execute the solution,
we find out that some of
the turns are only one way.
Now this particular solution fails.
In this particular domain, the cost
of executing a solution may be low,
therefore we can just go ahead and
execute it.
In other domains, the cost of execution
may in fact be quite high and
the best we can do is to first simulate
it before we decide to execute it.
>> So evaluation is built very
closely into our programming example.
Every time we run a program and see
whether or not it worked, we're in fact
evaluating whether or not our adaptation
successfully solved our new problem.
When it didn't, we return to
the adaptation phase and we try again or
we might return to the retrieval phase,
and
retrieve another case to
use to inform our solution.
>> In design more generally,
we can simulate the design, or
we can actually prototype a design.
Under the matter for
evaluating a design could be to
share it with other designers and
let them critique it.
So there are a number of different
methods that are possible for
evaluation as well.